from time to time
the academy bestows an honorary award
on a member of the film industry
sometimes for a body of work
sometimes for work done to better the
industry
sometimes for the influence created
among other filmmakers around the world
this year they honor a man who qualifies
in all three areas
and who is also unique in the history of
film
they call him sidney poitier
before sydney african-american actors
had to take supporting roles in major
studio films that were easy to cut out
in certain parts of the country
but you couldn't cut sidney poitier out
of a sidney poitier picture
he was the reason a movie got made
the first solo above the title
african-american movie star
he was unique
sidney poitier
oh
i arrived in hollywood at the age of 22
in a time different
than today's
a time in which the odds against my
standing here tonight 53 years later
would not have fallen in my favor
back then no route had been established
for where i was hoping to go
no pathway left in evidence for me to
trace
no custom
for me to follow
yet here i am this evening at the end of
a journey that in
1949 would have been considered almost
impossible
and in fact might never have been set in
motion
were there not an untold number of
courageous
unselfish choices
made by a handful of visionary american
filmmakers
directors writers and producers
each with a strong sense of citizenship
responsibility to the times in which
they lived
each unafraid to permit their art to
reflect their views and values ethical
and moral
and moreover acknowledge them as their
own
they knew the odds that stood against
them
and their efforts were overwhelming
and likely
could have proven too high to overcome
still those filmmakers persevered
speaking through their art to the best
in all of us
and i benefited from their effort
the industry
benefited from their effort
america benefited from their effort
and in ways large and small the world
has also benefited from their effort
therefore
with respect
i share
this great honor
with
the late joe mankowitz
the late
richard brooks
the late
ralph nelson
the late
daryl zanak
the late
stanley kramer
the mirrish brothers especially walter
whose friendship lies at the very heart
of this moment
guy green
norman jewison
and all others who have had a hand in
altering the odds for me
and for others without them
this most memorable moment would not
have come to pass
and the many
excellent young actors who have followed
an admirable fashion might not have come
as they have to enrich the tradition of
american filmmaking as they
have i accept this award in memory
of all the african-american actors and
actresses who went before me in the
difficult years
on whose shoulders i was privileged to
stand to see where i might go
my love
my love
and my thanks
to my wonderful
wonderful
wife
my children
my grandchildren
my agent and friend martin baum and
finally
finally to those audience members around
the world who have placed their trust in
my judgment as an actor and filmmaker i
thank
each of you for your support through the
years
thank you
you